everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're starting
our coverage of the 2018 World Chess
Championships I'm gonna go over some
details about the tournament and then we
will get into game number one for those
not familiar with the championship plays
every two years Magnus Carlsen the
champion has won the last three it'll be
one of the competitors and his opponent
who won the candidates tournament
earlier this year is Fabiano Caruana now
Magnus Carlsen 27 years old from Norway
we talked about won the last three
championships he is the defending
champion also ranked number one in the
world just so happens Fabiano his
opponent 26 years old is currently
ranked at number two in the world but he
is here not because of that rank but
because he did win that candidates
tournament earlier in the year he's
looking to become the first American to
win the World Championship since 1972
now this tournament is gonna take place
from November 9th to November 26th if
there is a tie at the end of that there
will be a day off and then tie breakers
on November 28th this is played in
London it's 12 matches it's the first
player to six and a half points so you
get a full point for a win you get half
a points for a draw so six and a half
points will be victorious if they are
tied six to six that's when we will have
those tie breakers so those are some
logistics around the match itself as far
as time controls every tournaments gonna
be different but for the World
Championship the first 40 moves they
have 100 minutes they get 30 seconds
after every move that they make after
they've moved 40 times they get an
additional 50 minutes and then after the
next 20 moves and they will get 15
minutes at it on no additional bonus
time will be added but they still do get
that 30 seconds at it after every single
moves also one thing to note is there
can be no drawls before Black's 30th
move which is always nice there have
been tournaments in the past where you'd
see some draws after move 17 or 20 very
disappointing for all the fans who wait
so long to see the World Championship so
there will be no drawls before you see
black playing at his 30th move so we'll
go ahead and get into it with game
number one Magnus Carlsen did win the
die roll he decided to play second so
he's gonna be playing the black pieces
Fabiano Caruana will play the white
pieces in game number one
Fabiano starts out with pawn to e4 met
by pawn c5 the Sicilian offense not f3
knight c6 Bishop to b5 so Fabiano right
out the bat not looking to go down the
main line if pawn d4 instead plays
Bishop b5 and then pawn to g6 so white
looking to give up the bishop here early
on in exchange for the double pawns on
the C file black on the other side
looking to think it was Bishop here to
g7 then it can cast on the King side if
he wants to he can later push forward
with his two central pawns but this is
how it usually goes for both sides so
Bishop to as c6 there is an exchange
right here black has the option to take
with either pawn taking with his deep on
does open up the door for his light
square bishop we get involved early for
the Queen to attack and if black ever
wanted to to castle on the Queen side
with a little bit more safety than if he
took with his pond from b7 pawn d3
solidifying the pawn chain also opening
up the door for the dark square bishop
to get involved into the game Bishop to
g7 pawn h3 just stopping the bishop to
coming down here to a g4 since the
lights where bishop is open here where
does it really go doesn't want to come
to e6 that blocks off the pawn from
pushing forward we can already see that
it can't come down here to f5 so that's
what
Fabiana is looking to do just stop the
bishop coming down here getting involved
into the game so Knight to f6 that
appear to c3 and then Knight to d7 so
magnus carlsen already looking to play
not the main line of what we would
expect from here you might see Queen to
c7 you could even see Queen to b6
logical just to castle on the King side
as well but once the maneuver
his nights around plays Knight to d7 we
see Bishop here to e3 pawn to e5 center
of the board castle on the Kings side
and then pawn to b6 and this is really
where you know all that all the theory
starts to change there's not really any
game if you look in in the past for
high-level that really plays this b6
move so Fabiana took a lot of time on
and this move and played at night to h2
and this took him eighteen minutes again
they start out with a hundred minutes on
their clock for the first 40 moves and
most of the time especially for whites
they have a lot of preparation they know
what their opponents gonna be doing and
all the variations they have a plan
doesn't take them very often to move
many times you're looking at one minute
for the moves if not sooner so to take
18 minutes for move number 10 was
surprising to see Knight here to f8 not
sure if that confuse Fabiano even more
but the next move took 12 minutes and
that is pawn to f4 I do think this is
the right tactic it anytime your
opponent's gonna move their knight back
to the 8th row it is time to attack
especially if you're a white you have to
really use that as an opportunity to
attack your opponent's I wish the knight
back here wasn't on h2 which he was a
little bit more forward but we do see an
attack starting from Fabiano on the
Kings side the board pond takes on F
Ford rook takes here Bishop to e6 almost
just assumed that Magnus would play
Knight to e6 just moving this Knights
around the board felt like this was the
right time getting involved into the
center of the board attack this rook
forced the rook to come back but instead
Magnus Carlsen he had a different plan
Bishop to e6 the rook still comes back
here to f2 but then pawn to h6 this is
another one of those move that just did
not expect to see here maybe now the
knight could come over here to d7 for me
or maybe Knight to f3 we could castle on
the King side very safe structure for
black I think this is completely fine
but as soon as we see
Ponta aged six this signifies that
blacks probably not looking to castle on
the kingside especially with this F file
semi-open file for white here can really
start to attack black does not want to
have any sort of weakness in front of
his king so instead magnus carlsen sees
an opportunity to push here on h6 and
then later on if he wants to he can
castle on the Queen side white plays
Queen to d2 just completing development
pawn to g5 so if you play a move you
gotta commit to that strategy that's
what manage Carlsen does he starts to
attack on the King side of the board
rook over here to f1 just starting the
attack wants to make sure that he's
controlling this F file right here Queen
down here to d6 Knight to g4 castle on
the Queen side as we talked about and
then Knight to f6 if you really look at
where White's going to go here there's
not a lot of great options one thing he
could try is pawn to a3 wants to get his
other Knight involved into the game but
right now it is tied down to protecting
this pond so could try something like
pawned a3 then get his not involved into
the game if he wants to that is one
option would take a few moves to move
that around instead decides to play
Knight to f6 Knight to d7 from Magnus
Carlsen offering up a trade white
decides not to go ahead and trade brings
his Knight back here to h5 Magnus
Carlsen sinner's both of his bishops now
always good to get those involved into
the center controls more area of the
board pawn to d4 so things get pretty
risky in my opinion for Fabiano pushing
so much material in front of his King
doesn't have a lot of king's safety
really gonna be using his pieces instead
of his pawns to protect so just
something to be aware of as magnus
carlsen is gonna be looking to attack
his opponent he can't try anything too
crazy here you know would be nice if he
could just come up and take with his
rook right here Bishop takes and then
rook comes up here but the problem is
when Queen comes over here to g6
attacking both the knights and the
rook comes back we already know what
happens this night is gonna fall right
here on g5 if it doesn't if we start to
see something instead okay it's just
going to be bad there's no way for a
white to hold on to them it's you're
already down in material so that's all
gonna be bad does not have that option
so instead decides to play after the
night here to d7 just comes back to h5
Bishop e5 and then pawn to g4 now we see
pawn to f6 so wants to make sure that
yes now that white has given up the
opportunity I'm not gonna see the rook
coming back here to the seventh rake any
longer pawn to b3 bishop up here to f7
attacking the knight white says okay
yeah that's fine I'm not gonna worry
about that right now as Magnus Carlsen
does have the option if he wants you to
go ahead and take this mint to right
here pawn could recapture you can see
rook to g8 just really start pushing
here we have the pond double pawns here
on the H foul but besides that no pawns
in front of the king that we might see
Magnus Carlsen tried that but instead
decides to go for more of a normal let's
build up approach don't want to do
anything too crazy until he feels really
confident about the attack so plays
Knight to f8 Knight takes here on f6 we
see Knight coming down here to e6 this
is interesting and what I always admire
about Magnus Carlsen he gives up a pawn
in material if you look at this the
knight here on D 7 is protecting this
pawn here on f6 he looks at this and
says okay yeah I'm gonna go and move my
knight here to f8 I'm gonna give up that
pawn because I really like my night here
on e6 I see a strong attack later on I
feel like I can get that material or
just have a better position I'm willing
to give up a pawn just for this move
right here not something that many
people would do I think
so after Magnus Carlsen does that Knight
comes back here to h5 where Fabiano was
before now he's just up in material
Magnus Carlsen now decides is the time
to go ahead and exchange the material so
Bishop takes now the Ponte
this sorta gets material back anytime
your opponent has double pawns on a file
especially on one of these outer files a
or H it's just so hard to protect these
so maybe Manish carlson is looking at
this thinking that this is worth it as
it does allow him to control more of the
center also opens up if he wants to
attack his opponents King on the
kingside Knight down here to f4 this is
a great little outpost both from the
pawn as well as the bishop Bishop takes
here the pawn recaptures just not as
good to take back with the bishop here
Knight - III just stops a lot of the
threats that magnus carlsen has so he
correctly decides to take with his pawn
here on f4 Fabiano plays rook to g2 just
already knowing that the rook is gonna
be coming to g8 and it does we do see
the Queen come to e2 want to start
getting the material off of the dark
square so as you start to approach the
middle game especially the endgame you
want to see if your opponent has one
maybe - Bishop doesn't really do too
much of a has two bishops but if it's
just one you can start to maneuver your
pieces on squares that are on the
opposite color for your opponent's
Bishop and it starts to negate the
threat that they can pose on you so you
can see right now all of the pieces as
well as the pawns they are all on light
squares this dark square Bishop is not
gonna be doing as much so just be
thinking about that in your own game
Fabiano now sees Magnus come down take
his rook here on g-tube he does
recapture with his own queen queen e6
Knight to f2 White's just playing
defense right now Magnus is completely
taking control of attacking his opponent
definitely has the edge in the game that
appeared to g4 to stop the attack Queen
to e8 now threatening this pawn on h5 as
we talked about very hard to control
both of the pawn specially when they're
on this outer rim so we see Magnus start
to attack that Queen to f3 Magnus
Carlsen is able to get that material
back so it definitely has the advantage
here now after King - f2
things get pretty tricky Fabiano only
has two minutes left on his clock he
still has eight moves that he has to get
through until he gets an additional 50
minutes on the clock but he's gonna be
scrambling and magnus carlsen has a ton
of time on his clock and he's gonna be
looking to attack his opponent Magnus
brings his bishop back here to c7 kini
to Queen to g5 a knight back here at h2
I just never really liked that the
knight coming back here it's not doing
too much back on h2 just playing defense
but not very active in the game pawn h5
rook here to F 2 and then Queen down to
g1 really like this move getting the
Queen very involved allows himself to
get the rook involved if he wants to as
well this Bishop is still defending this
pawn on f4 just such a dangerous
position for Magnus Carlsen night down
to f1 pawn h4 king over here to d2 king
- b7 wants to get it off this light
square diagonal also now it's just
completely protected doesn't have to
worry about anything coming back to the
8th ranked so great position from Magnus
Carlsen we see c3 Bishop to e5 just
getting a better position protecting
this pawn also attacking this pawn here
on c3 the King is really forced to now
defend that pawn King the c2 and then
Queen to g7 this is where I think Magnus
Carlsen made a huge blunder he had a
very good position right here and then
all of a sudden he comes back to g7 yes
this is doubling up to attack this pond
but this Bishop is also defending the
pawn on f4 if he takes the pawn he's
just gonna give up material right back
and he's no longer in his opponent's
territory now Fabiana he only has a few
seconds left on his clock by this time
and then he makes his last 40th move of
Knight to h2 so he does have extra time
added on and then from here Magnus
Carlsen plays Bishop to c3 now
afterwards they analyze a lot of
positions on the board they said really
this was a huge mistake
take from magnus carlsen he should have
played queen down to g1 i would argue
that the real mistake was ever bringing
the queen up here to g7 you couldn't
just kept it down here on g1 in the
first place but after magnus carlsen
played c3 he seemed pretty upset himself
shook his head during the match so at
the end of the day he you could tell
that he was not happy with the way that
he approached this position also knowing
that his opponents was under time
control it almost felt like Magnus
Carlsen was try to speed up his own
moves
so that Fabiana didn't have any of his
time thinking and trying to rush him as
well madness I think probably should
have taken some more time and just said
hey Fabiano I'm not gonna worry about
his time control I'm gonna figure out
the best move probably would not have
played Queen back to g7 but in the game
played Bishop to c3 and then Queen takes
here on f4 magnus brings his bishop back
here to d4 it's a great outpost also
attacking the rook here on f2 Fabiana
took some time there's a few reasons for
that one is he just got a lot of time on
his clock so he can actually look at the
position figure out how he is going to
continue because he's been speed racing
for the last few moves couldn't really
figure out how he's going to finish the
game but also this is the last chance
that he has in the game to see if he
wants to go for something maybe more
than the draw or if he wants to go ahead
and draw so his options so everyone is
aware of that what he's looking at is
one rook to e2 this says yeah I'm going
to continue and try for win I can push
the pawn up now I can get the knight
involved into the game I'm going to try
for something here the other one is to
say I'm gonna try for a draw and that
would be Queen to f7 trying to get
mature off the board trying to minimize
what man is crossing can do with the
powerful pieces this is check forcing
the Queen to come off now after the rook
comes here it's just much harder for
Magnus to win from here still possible
but definitely something that Fabiano
feels like if I play this maybe I can
get an easier drawl so in the game
that's exactly what we saw we see Queen
to f7 Fabiano opting to go for the draw
here so King to a6 we do see the Queen
take on g7 and then the rook take on g7
don't want to capture with the bishop
because this blocks off the rook from
getting involved why is that important
now the rook can come up here to f5 very
active rook from white see how this is
different where if the rook takes the
rook no longer come up here to f5
because now the rook comes down to G to
check attacking the knight as well so
this is a terrible position for white
wants to have an active rook but cannot
do that because of after the rook
ticking here he's forced to move his
rook over here to e2 really only the
option here is to start pushing with his
pawn but then we're gonna see the rug
come down here to g3 gobble up material
and no side has the advantage of stars
pushing it we will see that come to
fruition Knight up here to g4 rook takes
on h3 pawn 'if I've rook to f3 wants to
make sure that we're consuming over here
to stop this pond cannot promote or that
would be a victory for Fabiano rook to
f8 pawn 7 rook e8 Knight up here to h6
pawn down h3 Knight f5 defending this
pawn on e7 Bishop to f6 pawn a3 pawn b5
so both sides just moving on the Queen
side but really there's going to be an
exchange coming up so after the bishop
takes on a7 we do see the knight take
and then pawn over here to h2 Fabiano's
forced to take here cannot allow his
opponent to promote to a queen so after
the rook takes now the rook takes here
on e7 and then we get into the in game
now in this position they have played 55
moves 99 percent of players in this
position are going to just agree to a
draw it's the first game it's almost
always a draw in the first game float we
see at these high level tournaments it's
just what happens but Magnus Carlsen is
that 1% that just continues to play on
he has an advantage in material one pawn
and he wants to play until the very very
end to see if he can find a small
mistake that his opponent makes and turn
that into a victory also if you remember
from the first time that he played Vichy
and on one of the things that he said he
was trying to do is wear out his
opponent not necessarily in one game but
he knew as a marathon and he knew that
every match if he could wear out his
opponent that would be better for him
because he felt like in the long run he
was the better player he just didn't
tire like other players so I did go
through all those moves fairly fast why
because they played for hours and that
was another 60 moves of the players
going back and forth Magnus Carlsen at
the end of it said yeah I would have
just kept going on and on but after 115
moves I thought I would give a draw on
the other side Fabiana said it was
torture to try to defend Magnus Carlsen
with the small advantage making sure
that I did not make any mistake so even
though they drew Magnus Carlsen with the
black pieces getting a draw feels much
better especially when his opponent says
that was completely exhausting almost
feels like a win from Magnus Carlsen but
we do have a draw in the books
knowing that Fabiano was down he did say
that he felt so good to get a draw
because he felt like he could have
easily lost that game Magnus did have
the advantage did make a blunder Magnus
Carlsen said he should not have taken
with his Bishop here on c3 that was a
huge mistake so at the end of the day
great game by both players tried to go
for the win didn't see any boring chess
by any means so I'll be excited to see
Magnus Carlsen play the white pieces
tomorrow we're really going to be
looking at playing two days alternating
white and
lack and then taking a rest day so in
two days we will have our first rest day
but hopefully you guys enjoyed game
number one hopefully you're excited
about this tournament going to be a fun
match to follow but thanks for watching
this video in particular and I'll see
you guys tomorrow for game number two